[Music]
hello to all viewers welcome back to
another episode of what's up Roth hello
Walter how are you doing
I'm very well into you I'm glad you're
feeling well yeah as a lockdown in the
store feeling well still in interesting
days looking forward to what's happening
next
some people might be negative about
everything but aren't we excited about
everything that's happening yes it has
its positive aspects now will you open
up for us with a word of Prayer please
Heavenly Father as we discuss issues
involving your truth especially the
truth for this time I pray that you will
be with our deliberations and guide our
thoughts in Jesus name Amen amen on the
previous episode we mentioned that we
were going to discuss the spirit of
prophecy in more broader terms but
before we get to that we've received
some interesting videos for among others
dr. Shiva dr. Bhutta and then there's
been some questions about Q the Q anons
I don't know if you know anything about
these yes yes we've looked at those so
what can you tell us that's interesting
about these things that you find I'm
sorry I'm sure the viewers would like to
know for instance what have you heard of
Q what have you heard about this a non
so why do you think about these videos
that surfaces about the swamp that will
be drained and the Illuminati that will
be exposed
dr. Fauci and the new world order which
will be prevented as all of those issues
well before we get there let me first
talk a little bit about Hegelian
dialectic basically what the what the
principle is is that you put opposites
into the world and then you rub the
opposites up against each other until
you finally get what
called the synthesis now it's
interesting that if you study the
workings of the Jesuits for example in
in their earth and as it is recorded in
the congressional records miss they
state quite clearly what their aim is
it's the destruction of Protestantism
that is the aim of the Jesuits and we
mustn't lose that aim out of our sight
yes now what Protestantism are they're
interested in destroying in the time
that we are living in any Protestantism
that doesn't recognize the supremacy of
the Pope because that is another one of
their stated aims to restore the
supremacy of the papacy and then they
state quite clearly that it is the duty
of the Jesuits to climb in the
hierarchies into positions of power and
where they can act as as instigators of
the particular directions in government
that they want to have and that's what
organizations like the Knights of
Columbus etcetera all about that's
that's why they exist that's their
stated aim
that's why William bar when he was asked
about his affiliation to the Knights of
Columbus as we have already stated said
no it won't interfere with his work
because he will render unto Caesar what
is due unto Caesar but as we said
there's only one Caesar in the world
today who bears the title of Caesar
which is Pontifex Maximus therefore he
must be Caesar if he has the title of
Caesar and that's the Pope so when he
answered I will render unto Caesar what
is to enter Caesar he wasn't breaking
his oath in any way that he made to the
Knights of Columbus right and the
Jesuits do the same they categorically
state in their oath of allegiance that
they will defend opposite sides of an
issue even acrimoniously they will seem
to be at odds with each other fighting
each other like like
cats and dogs so that in the synthesis
that comes in the end Mother Church will
be glorified so that's the aim even up
to the point of death even to the point
of death correct that that is their
stated aim now that's why I'm always
fascinated when I see the role players
and I see that we spoke last time about
4c for example and in those videos that
you mentioned they really hammer Bill
Gates
foresee right and say that these people
are in cahoots and they have one idea
and that is to inoculate the whole world
and to give them the mark of the beast
and you know how the Christian world out
there feels about the mark of the beast
and they're all convinced that this is a
microchip that will be placed into you
into your skin etc etc so this is what
their great fear is and what if you have
a savior now one who will arise and will
save you from this terrible swamp this
deep state conspiracy to make everybody
a robot so that you cannot think for
yourselves and I mean there are videos
about unmix
fun vex yes the vaccination for the
fundamentalist that interferes with the
gene that helps you to make your frontal
lobe decisions on a religious basis etc
and to make everybody what they call
normal so we've seen all of those now
are we going to run with all of these
God wants people to make a decision
based on rationality emotional decision
is it's like the wind it's here today
and gone tomorrow you must have a
rational basis so I don't believe that
God would permit humanity to be vexed
out of its conscious decision making
capacity
God will not permit it because if people
cannot make a choice
then they cannot be held accountable and
God wants to have people to be
accountable yes so what about if you
look at this scenario foresee as we saw
was Jesuit trained the administration is
Ches who had trained the both on the
same same team right yes and the one is
accusing the other one and in those
videos they're saying that the law has
been broken that these viruses were
manufactured and that it was an illegal
action that they have one aim and that
is you know to get all of humanity into
their brainwashed system etc etc and now
you need a savior and that Savior is Q
and nobody knows who Q is and some say Q
is Donald Trump some say Q is a Kennedy
that has died and wrought really died
and will resurrect and all of those
things are fascinating and even if they
were true and even if it did happened
wouldn't change one iota because they're
still playing both sides of the coin the
master plan is unchanged the master plan
is unchanged so I would say don't get
distracted by all of these things that
are out there it is he's stated aim to
always add truth to elements of
falsehood it is the most dangerous thing
when you mix truth Ameri
it's like adding poison to a wonderful
juice it is the poison that will kill
you even if it is in a wonderful juice
so if we look at it in terms of
achillion dialectics yes so what you
have bad guys and you have good guys so
you're playing bad cop bad cop good cop
and what if a savior appears who says I
will save you from all this will not the
religious world rejoice this
they not say finally we're getting rid
of all the evil in the world finally
someone standing up and arresting all of
these child traffickers and the
pedophiles and no matter where they are
whether they are in the Vatican or
whether they're in the royal families or
whether it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter we'll arrest them all and then
we'll clean up the world and we'll
dedicate ourselves to what our
Constitution is after all that we are a
people under God bring morality back
morality back into the system and people
the church will say hallelujah and isn't
Putin doing the same thing yes didn't
you also bring God back into the
Constitution and say we are a people
under God and isn't this a means to
bring the world together and say listen
to we have really failed we need to
drain the swamp
we need to clean up the act and then
people will look to them as the saviors
the ones who are cleaning the act no
matter what name you attach to them they
brought peace to the world yes and
that's a Bible talk about that and
whether it is a Trump or whether it is a
Kennedy or whether it is a prince
whoever Andrew who cares the bottom line
is back to morality back to the neck
knowledge meant of God in the center and
then when you acknowledge God then you
also have to worship God so why not
dedicate the day to the worship of God
and what is the consensus out there what
they should that be what are we seeing
in the world this Sunday so we've been
saved from the mark of the beast the
implant only to be forced to keep the
mark of the beast which is a cognitive
decision between the precepts of God and
the precepts of man and moral decisions
so who will benefit in the end mother
church through the sigilian dialectic so
I look at the role players and I know
really interested who's bad-mouthing who
and who is wicked and who has been
drained from the swamp I look at the
former CIA directors
they've all been removed because they
were part of the swamp they will suggest
were trained they were all Jesuit trying
nice and that amazing
so the Jesuits are removing the Jesuits
that don't make any sense
no only in the light of the conflict
between good and evil can we understand
these things and if we don't believe
that there is a conflict between good
and evil
we'll get lost in the maze yes what if
they should erase the Pope on what basis
well there are there are these rumors
that arrest warrants have already been
issued that he stepped down from his
position that he is in self-isolation
as it were there are among the Catholics
there are the conservative circles which
claim that he's an anti Pope and that
the real Pope is really in the wings he
stole there is not gone Benedictus and
books have been written even you know
amongst the people that that believed
present truth stating that that is the
one that will rise because it's the one
that isn't the one that is not and will
come back etcetera that it'll be
Benedict you know what I hope they're
right because these people are so old it
would mean that the end is right here
yes I wouldn't really change in yeah but
the fact of the matter is we cannot
think in terms of those futuristic ideas
and haven't we seen that high placed
Catholic officials Cardinals have been
arrested some have been exonerated now
as in the case in Australia and people
are up in arms why should they get away
with it and this
that yes we might see a few of these
arrests of high-profile people and the
cleaning up of the AK and going back to
moral standards I find it interesting
that post Corona the governments are
saying we have a new economy coming all
the all the governments are saying this
even here our own government even our
own government a new economy a new era
it's everything is new a new
relationship between governments a new
everything's new it sounds like a new
world order without a new world order
right so whether the one party wins or
the other party wins and the so-called
battle between the deep state and and
the others it's actually irrelevant
there will be a new order it might not
look like they thought it would look but
it will be a new order yes and it will
not as they all say be business as usual
and they are all talking about a six day
workweek to make up for the losses etc
etc so again we're heading for the same
thing so your question Sep the Sunday
law according to the Adventists you just
mentioned a six-day Work Week yes just
explain a little bit more about that is
the law only gonna be that you can't you
must worship on Sunday I would have no
problem with the law like that constant
tighten made constant I made a law which
says that you must keep sunday holy and
you may not work on a Sunday
that's the Sunday law he actually had a
few exceptions yes in that law but you
had to keep Sunday but the Roman
Catholic Church didn't have
Constantine's law the Roman Catholic
Church stated categorically Christians
shall not Jew it dies and be idle on the
the Saturday they shall work on that day
that was the law so the anti Sabbath law
of the Roman Catholic Church actually
enforces working six days and resting on
the Sunday that is the law that I am
waiting for let's just go back in
history a little bit not so far back
when they when there was this great
bailout when the government's bailed out
the banking systems and the nations had
gone bankrupt and they had to be bailed
out and in Europe there was major
consternation and Greece was in a
turmoil and Italy and all these
countries were experiencing great
financial turmoil then the European bank
spent huge amounts of money to bail out
these economies and the banking system
one of the laws that was made was that
there should be a six day workweek and
if a government didn't comply with those
laws they would fall foul of the
agreement of the central banks that
loaned the money and I find it
interesting that the governments are now
announcing like our own government
announced that they were receiving money
from the IMF and from you know all of
these major banking institutions I
cannot for one moment believed that
those loans do not come with strings yes
and who controls these banking systems
who owns the Bank of America is a lot
the Jesuits and control these things and
they say you know the Rothschilds what
is the word Rothschild mean means a
whole and if you look up in the
encyclopedia the Jewish encyclopedia it
will tell you that it is vatican bankers
so these are front Jews for the Vatican
system so it is Rome that controls the
the systems of the world yes
so that that's exactly what will happen
with this I believe a 66 day workweek
will be the answer to the crisis and it
will come country of the country until
eventually through the leading of the
United States every country will adopt
it yes and the South African government
sent out a document on education and one
of the scenarios on when the pandemic
subsided and they can go back to school
is that to catch up the last days then
chilled people's might be forced to go
to school on the Saturday so the same
suggestion has now been made in Germany
as well so this is something that is
happening it starts small and then it
grows we mentioned a small time of
trouble this is not once it gradually
comes in it gradually sneaks in and
before you know it it's there yes okay
so and the Pope is it possible that he
could be arrested well as they say
there's an arrest warrant out for him I
have to see things like that before I
believe them because there are so many
wins of stories and doctrines blowing
out there that if you had to believe
every single one of them you'd probably
go crazy but as I said the conservative
Catholics consider him an anti path and
that the real one will eventually come
out of the woodwork or another one will
be elected in his place or whatever the
scenario it doesn't that doesn't matter
it doesn't matter he will still be the
moral force in the world if there is
this one they will be a natural yes and
how much better if you want to think in
their terms if you have now this cleaned
up system the swamp is drained the
church has been purified of all of those
liberals and now we're getting back to
serious morality well then she still
comes out shining like
yes we can bring in the spirit of
prophecy because the spirit of prophecy
has quite a lot to say about the Pope
and all these things that are happening
would you care to give us an
introduction on what this second leg of
Adventism consists of yes this is of
course a very hot potato the spirit of
prophecy we did to us here I did a
series a little while back with France
what do please see yes on the lesser
light and the greater light well we
discussed it in great detail so perhaps
you can put a link in there and say look
at this I will do it and further study
I've also given some lectures in the
past on this issue correct
God's guiding gift there's a lecture
with all the Bible verses and everything
associated with it and the events that
took place if you put that link in there
then people just get the details we
don't have to repeat them in this forum
but the question is why does
adventism claim that it has this
additional prophetic backing in terms of
the writings of lng white now do we need
something like inspired writings for the
times we are living in do we not need
them well you know if you look at a
couple of Bible verses in this
connection if you go to the book of
Ephesians for example or first
Corinthians you just go to first
Corinthians okay
first Corinthians and we'll look there
at chapter one it tells you about the
spiritual gifts and we read there from
verse four I thank my god always on your
behalf for the grace of God which is
given you by Jesus Christ that in
everything you are enriched by him in
all utterance and in all knowledge even
as the testimony of Christ was confirmed
in you
there's the testimony of Christ so that
you become and so that you come behind
in no gift waiting for the coming of our
Lord Jesus Christ
so the testimony of Christ must be
confirmed so that you come behind in no
gift as you wait for the coming of the
Lord Jesus we shall also confirm you
unto the end that you may be blameless
in the day of our Lord Jesus Christ so
there is this issue of spiritual gifts
and in Ephesians we don't have to go
there it tells you what these gifts are
there's the gift of of preaching there's
the gift of healing there's the gift of
tongues is the gift of prophecy there
are all of these issues now see if you
go to Revelation chapter 17 then we read
there and this is a well-known verse
that the remnant that comes out of the
great conflict between Christ and Satan
and a church is always described as a
woman I have likened you unto a woman a
comely woman the church or a bride
you're a bride to Christ correct and the
woman which thou sawest is the great
city which reigneth over the kings of
the earth it tells you that this the
city this enemy city will reign over the
over the earth so that's the one side
and if you go to chapter 12 and you read
verse 17 then you see that the dragon is
wroth with the woman and this is now
God's people compared with a woman so
you have Babylon compared to a woman
that's a church system and then you have
God's people the remnant compared to a
woman and went to make war with the
remnant overseas so they will be this
clash between the two systems and it
tells you the attributes which keep the
commandments of God yes as opposed to
the commandments of men
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
so now Paul said that you become behind
in no gift as you wait for the coming of
the Lord now you go to Revelation
chapter 19 and you read there in verse
10 the angel that is talking to John in
in this revelation John is so
overwhelmed that he falls at the angel's
feet and the angel says that he
shouldn't do it and I fell at his feet
to worship him and he said to me see
that thou do it not I am by
fellow-servant and of thy brethren that
have the testimony of Jesus yes
worship God for the testimony of Jesus
is the spirit of prophecy so one of the
attributes of God's people at the end is
that the spirit of prophecy that Timothy
had and that Paul homeland and that the
Prophet said will be repeated at the end
of time now it's always fascinating to
me that in the time period when the
three angels messages went into the
world as the prophetic time period of
Daniel chapter 9 the 2300 day prophecy
came to an end which was 1844 there
arose a number of people that were
prophesying it was Joseph Smith of the
Mormons Ellen White of the Adventists
the shakers they were all in in this
prophetic mode and the question is how
do you distinguish which is true and
which is false because the Bible clearly
says that the remnant will have this
gift and that those who wait for the
coming of the Lord will not
behind in any of the gifts so how do you
determine whether someone is a prophet
or someone is not a prophet
well you study the attributes of the
Prophet and the Bible tells you clearly
that you should test the prophets for
example if you go to 1 Thessalonians
chapter 5 let's just go there ont
solonian is chapter 5
look at verse 19 it says there this is
interesting
quench not the Spirit despise not
prophesying prove all things hold fast
that which is good
abstain from the appearance of evil so
in other words the Bible tells you you
shouldn't despise prophesying but you
should test it yes how do you test it
biblical criteria absolutely and what
are the biblical criteria well this
external but also the preaching all
right so there are external factors and
then there are the issues that are
raised when a prophet speaks it must be
in harmony with a Bible no prophet can
contradict the previous prophecy
so whatever the Prophet says must be in
harmony with the word so if the Bible
says for example that you must keep the
commandments of God and somebody
prophesized and says that the
commandments of God have been done away
with well then you have a choice to make
yeah which one are you going to believe
what the Prophet says must come true
there are certain things like
conditional prophecies like Jonah who
was preaching and it didn't come true
because they for for the conditions
right they became converted so what the
prophet preachers must come true
it must be in harmony with the word the
life of the Prophet must be in harmony
with God's principles you cannot have
one who is living a lie senseless life
and then pretends to be a prophet of God
because when they sin in the camp God
doesn't speak right now that you
mentioned that at Prophet what the
Prophet says must come true it was
interesting to me that I've actually
read a few of these prophets and some of
them haven't acknowledged they have a
list of thoth of their prophecies that
didn't come true so they already
disqualify themselves just by
acknowledging that there were some of
the prophets the prophecies that didn't
come true absolutely so how do you know
that someone is a prophet or not so you
have to follow these biblical criteria
and there are some physical criteria as
well Daniel describes exactly how a
prophet goes into vision for example
what happens and if you study L&G wide
she was investigated not in some corner
but in front of thousands yes by doctors
by doctors and she was healed every
single one of these criteria now one of
the criteria which doesn't stand so
directly in the Bible with but which is
absolutely the case when you study the
prophets they were all hated will happen
to poor old Jeremiah they put him in
stocks that they tore up is is his
writings they hated him so one of the
criteria a prophet is is never love now
they love the tombs of the prophets but
they don't love what the prophet said
why not one and poor old Isaiah was sawn
in half and so what is the case with LNG
white there are two prophets which stand
out in her time energy white and Madame
Blavatsky
those two and they are contemporaneous
and the one publishes in a journal which
is called Lucifer Lucifer that's blood
skiers and the other one says we have no
Creed except the Bible read your Bible
as it stands the one uplifts the Bible
the other one denigrates the Bible and
Blavatsky was in favor of the
Alexandrian and cinetic Alexandrian text
absolutely plovar Sookie favored figs
Alexandrian text and she said that the
modern versions and those who you know
wrote the manuscripts on which they are
based that only a Kabbalist
would be able to achieve this rewriting
of the document so that the entire
Saints of what was written before has
been changed so I find that very
interesting you know when you study the
enemy then often you can discover the
truth by contrast so if you go to the
web pages and the great leadership
excellence in the world take the United
Nations for example who is exalted there
L&G white oak Levites give me the entire
Theosophical movement with Alice a
Bailey and Blavatsky and all of them oh
and you have all of these temples as
part of the United Nations movement and
these earth movements and and you know
it is absolutely horrendously occult yes
but they are the heroes of the world and
the Prophet that speaks about the Bible
and trusting the words in the Bible and
we have no Creed other than the Bible
that prophet is my lion
and hate it in my own case I I always
tell the story about I got to know the
spirit of prophecy writings I see you
have a book there what's it called the
history of redemption the history of
redemption it's a magnificent book with
many of books and writings in it is all
in one compilation she is one of them
the most celebrated authors in the world
the woman whoo woman author who wrote
more than any other she she should be
amongst the great authors of the world
she should have received every literary
prize that the world could throw at
someone of that nature and she got not
one of them it's interesting that even
some very prominent media and radio
broadcasters actually claimed that and
they weren't Adventists but they'd read
let's say the desire of Ages must rank
amongst the best books ever but how I
got to know it it's because a colleague
found me and used very derogatory
language about it to such an extent that
I thought that's interesting why the
animosity yeah so I started reading and
I've never looked back if you want to
know whether this woman was inspired do
yourself a favor
go read the desire of Ages go read steps
to Christ go read the great controversy
and based on what you read and not what
you hear make a decision when you look
at the web pages that are so
horrendously negative yes then if you
base your decision on that then you will
have not done an empirical study is this
is this in harmony with God's Word or is
it not in harmony with God's Word why
would why would a remnant church need a
guiding gift like this I mean take a
church I don't want to run churches down
now but even though some of the things
are so blatantly obvious that you just
sit and said whoa and people still
retain those changes take the moments
for example Joseph Smith through the
gift of sin man can achieve joy I mean
that sort of makes you stagger or their
prophet Brigham Young which said the
devil told the truth about godhood I
would not have mother Eve must eating
the forbidden fruit for anything through
the gift again of sin then you must know
man joy I mean there's something
blatantly wrong with that kind of
statement right so yes so you have that
kind of prophecy on the one end and
everybody is quite happy but when it
comes to L&G white whoever lifts Jesus
who have chip lifts the law of God then
all of a sudden she must be a false
prophet right and they are they are just
thousands of statements of all her false
prophets prophecies and they are just as
many books written against all of those
statements and you could you could study
this ad infinitum fact of the matter is
if you take our writings and you read it
do they take you away from this word of
God more do they take you towards to the
Word of God what's your experience by
the way well it was when I came into
adventism I barely knew about Ellen
White well nobody did right the
best-kept secret yeah and then
eventually the same happened similar to
what you had and the people that were
not happy that I've become Adventist
were continually telling me that now
this sect is just worshiping Ellen White
and
all her doctrines and all these things
and I said I don't even know who Ellen
White isn't the same I interrupt you
there he's so are you telling me that
you didn't become an Adventist because
of the writings of Ellen gee why'd you
become an Adventist because of the Word
of God
yes I can I can vouch for then I never
knew her no even when I was in the
church already I never knew anything and
even when I was when I was in the church
you know much animosity towards her were
in the church uh-huh and that surprised
you yes because now in new Adventists we
come in we stop and I'm confronted with
Ellen White I start reading a bit and I
said to wow there's something yeah
eventually I really started reading and
then I don't on me this is impossible
that she can be a false prophet in
telling these and as I began to
communicate what I have been reading
people in the church started this
distancing themselves so that was and
you mentioned in a in a sermon that you
did that revelation 12:17 that you
mentioned they have the testimony of
Jesus it's not just that they believe in
the prophets you said they that that
word says they must own that it must be
present in me or something like that can
you just explain that that sentence to
me because that made that that brought a
lot of us here are they that keep the
commandments and have the testimony yeah
now if you have it and it's part and
parcel of you now does the Adventist
Church in its fundamental beliefs claim
that they believe in the spirit of
prophecy as manifested in the writings
of Ellen G white and the answer is yes
now where does the greatest opposition
come from with regard to that from
inside or from outside
inside correct it's interesting that the
makeup reaches of the world and you can
mention them any one of them you know
well let's say Billy Graham or any one
of them that they have desire of Ages on
their shelves and that they study them
and some of their greatest sermons come
out of this but nobody knows that it was
basically based on the writings of Ellen
G wife no so why is it necessary for God
to put something like that into the
church why was it necessary that the
early church had prophets why was it
necessary that the church should besides
the word also be guided by the spirit
because every time when there was a
prophet they had the Word of God
up until now absolutely not when Paul
preached to the Jews did he preach to
them what the spirit told him or did he
preach from the Word of God from the
world he preached from the Word of God
where did Jesus sent him after he's
convicted a conversion he sent him to
the church he sent him to the church now
this is this is important so your
conviction that you eventually preach is
from the Word of God but how did he get
there because he was using that same
word of god to persecute God's people in
the beginning what changed his eyes
opened and through the spirit of
prophecy
he started understanding what the Bible
said about the Messiah how he would come
that he would suffer etc so in this
Babylonian confusion that we have at the
end of time where there are thousands of
churches each one teaching the weirdest
things how do we get to the point where
we get back to this world and God in His
mercy
I gave this church a simple direct
language that enlightens this book so it
is this book the Bible that is my Creed
it is the Bible I base my faith on but
to understand it and to understand the
nuances for example when it comes to the
way the Bible is written type and anti
Tigers I mean when you read the Bible
and the story is just a story
well what impact does it have mmm if
it's just a story it's something that
happened in the past but what if it is a
typology of a greater reality in the
future now I would never have discovered
this beautiful aspect of typology if I
hadn't read patriarchs and prophets
suddenly all the stories in the Old
Testament come to life this and they're
not dead stories about the past there
are stories which enlighten the present
and without it I would not have been
able to see it and once you've been
nudged in that direction you start
reading this book and the whole book
comes to life that's so true you know
once you read a book like patriarchs and
prophets or even great controversy if
you keep your Bible next to you and
every time she reads passages or refers
to passages in the Bible you can read
that passage you will find that almost
all if not more of your time you will
spend in them in the Bible exactly she
doesn't take you away from it she leads
you to it so she is the lesser light
pointing you to the greater light and if
it weren't for that then we could be so
confused in the end by all the winds of
doctrine that you're listening to the
winds but what about the word and that's
one of the reasons why I
of the spirit of prophecy you know I
think the people out in the world are
scared of prophets oh yeah because there
are so many false prophets the problem
so whenever you hear somebody's got a
prophet oh no we must stay away because
that verse that jesus said beware of
false prophets now everybody is a false
prophet now so we haven't had actually
any true ones but it says test the
spirit don't despise prophesying so they
must be a true prophet if you are not to
despise it and if there is a true one
then you have to use the biblical
criteria to determine whether she is
true or whether she is not now I've been
involved in in preaching this word for
well over 30 years right and don't you
think that every single negative that is
in any way even remotely possible has
been thrown at my head and have some of
them sort of stunned me yes of course
now I could be an ostrich and I can put
my my head in the sand
and I can say whoa this must be a false
prophet mm-hmm but every single one that
I've I've studied because I don't want
to be deceived no every single one of
them she has come out as the true light
and the accusation as totally false is
often based on complete misunderstanding
of even the basic plan of salvation in
the sanctuary message for example either
that or a quote out of context yes
that's that happens a lot don't I do
that with the Bible exactly it's
interesting if you have to study
inspired documents or like the Bible how
do you study them you've got a certain
criteria and that applies to the spirit
of prophecy as well yes don't take
things out of context
the Manute explai a big role and
especially the historical grammatical
interpretation and people that look at
the Bible such as higher critics they
come and look at the verse and they say
and maybe if there's something like
looks like it's contradictory they'll
say however this is not true what's the
answer whereas if you are a Bible
believer really and you want to see what
the words is you say why don't I
understand what Cydia yes there must be
something else I must do deeper study
and with it the spirit of prophecy L&G
White's writings we've got the same
people we'll take a quote and then this
is what you said so she must be a false
prophet you must have this repeat the
same principle to the taste
why don't I understand this and then go
into further stat correct so you can
read contrasting statements in the Bible
and say that the Bible contradicts
itself I think somebody once sent me a
document with about 3000 contradictions
and in the Bible you and when you read
them you say whoa yeah you know you're
very taken aback and I actually did the
trouble to go through those statements I
don't know to which number I got when I
finally realized you know what these
people don't understand very basic
things in the Bible like let's say for
example in one of the Gospels you will
have an event described and it'll say it
was on this day this time etc etc and
the next gospel describes the exact same
event with different times different
days then you say one of the two is
wrong and then you discard it and they
make big scenes about how the Bible is
contradicted itself from that not even
two Gospels are in harmony and then when
you do a little bit of a deeper study
you find out the one is using Roman
reckoning and the other one is using
Hebrew Rickon
and then the times differ yeah like
Daniel was in his third year and
Nebuchadnezzar was in his second year
but there's a kanay that in my race that
i can that be so they must be wrong
right one of them must be wrong one of
the statements but in Babylonian
reckoning they had an ascension year and
then they counted the so it is not a
disharmony and the same applies to L&G
white they say she contradicts herself
here and there and if you study them
then you see they don't really
understand yes is the issue and so many
of these this just disappear when you
when you do a deeper study for me
personally the deep you study and I've
mentioned now this hermeneutical way of
studying all this I haven't study I
didn't study it learn like that I just
read a books as it stands as it stands
yes and it is truly amazing what
insights into the Bible I've gotten out
of it I've only been blessed by reading
their writings well I can only
understand only say that I read the
Bible and you have this confusion that
develops in your mind between the God of
the Old Testament and the god of the New
Testament if you even read what Dawkins
writes for example how he he hates the
God of the Old Testament and says the
New Testament version in Jesus is now
better because you know one is sickly
sentimental the other one is his
whatever the most was the worst names
that he can possibly think of and once
you start reading the spirit of prophecy
the character of God becomes clear yes
and you see that there is really no
disharmony between the God of the Old
Testament and the god of the New
Testament there is perfect harmony and
you start understanding how God works
and how he thinks and all of those
so-called contra
addictions disappear in the mist
definitely like mist before the Sun now
it becomes so much more clear and it's
colorful once you read the spirit of
prophecy the Bible is quietly it tells
you that we should believe in the
prophets and we will be established that
I mas that says that I believe and this
is exactly it if you want to be
established God in his in his wisdom
gave this prophetic gift to the last
church to the remnant that keeps the
commandments and if that gift is not
there then it cannot be the remnant
because according to the criteria it has
to be there so like it or hate it it has
to be there now you can use the Bible as
I have like a hammer and you can use the
writings of Ellen G white like a hammer
exactly depending on what you quote you
can use the Bible as the most soothing
solve on your wounds yes you can use the
writings of Ellen G wide like the most
soothing solve on your wounds and that's
the nature of the Word of God the Word
of God will strike you and hurt you and
then bind you up and heal you and she
will do the same so the two spirits are
in total harmony with each other there
is a rebuke and there is love and there
is healing and I would not want to be
without it especially in the times that
we are living in that's interesting that
you mentioned it because I just want to
also put this in once you've read the
desire of Ages and you've really made
Jesus then you can rego on and you see
the other things like great controversy
and we can clearly see where we are
heading in this world absolutely and
it's
it's not frightening it's actually
uplifting to be seeing the things
happening before our eyes prophecy being
fulfilled and knowing that Jesus is
coming soon what is it that the world
says just just look carefully at the
world when things go wrong on this
planet and they're constantly going
wrong yes natural disasters you name it
coronavirus you can call it whatever you
like the question is always where is God
in all of this why doesn't the act is
the impotent is you're not doing
anything what's the problem with God
whereas if you understand it in the
light of the great controversy between
good and evil you know that God is
absolutely in control complete control
and he's so comforting to know that what
you are seeing happening in the world is
actually the fulfillment of prophecy if
it weren't so bad we wouldn't be
understanding the real issues so it is
comforting as you say differently
and one last point that I would also
just like to make is that it's going to
be hard and I think I'll have to phrase
this carefully but it's going to be hard
for anybody to stand in the coming days
without the Bible and the spirit of
prophecy the fortification the one
supports the other and if you have them
both then you are more fortified and of
course both of them require obedience to
God's precepts God's precepts and what
are God's precepts they are spelled out
in the Bible and clearly spelled out in
the spirit of prophecy so if you apply
them to your life then the channels of
your mind become clearer and you can
understand the spirit speaking to you
through the Word of God
it always has to speak through the Word
of God if the spirit of prophecy were
not in harmony with the Word of God I
could never accept that meeting but I
found it to be in harmony with the Word
of God and so I would encourage the
viewers to study it the proof of the
pudding is always in the eating take a
book like the great controversy if you
want to understand how you are saved
read chapter 7 in steps to Christ it is
the most beautiful chapter it is so
Protestant so evangelical it is so
beautiful that nobody can misunderstand
what Paul is writing in the book of
Romans or in any other his epistles that
are hard to understand once you've read
a simple little chapter in the book
steps to Christ or if you want to know
about Jesus who read the desire of Ages
if you want to get to know the God of
the Old Testament read patriarchs and
prophets if you want to know what the
issues are that are happening before our
eyes now read the great controversy now
these are things which fortify the mind
with good things don't read the
Blavatsky's of this world that that
glorify Lucifer read those that glorify
Christ amen can I close off with whether
we'll have police certainly may our
Heavenly Father what a privilege to have
you in our lives thank you for blessing
us thank you for showing us the way in
your word help us to be good lights out
there and to spread your word among
other people bless everybody that have
looked at this discussion and please
send your Holy Spirit to protect us in
the bedlam of noise that there is in the
world in Jesus name Amen
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click yes when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time